New Hampshire is famously hard to pull
which is why we decided to interrupt an
adult hockey game and take a very
different approach to predictions we
handed out pucks representing nearly
every candidate in the race
president Trump included political polls
are off and wrong so we're letting the
hockey gods decide today you all have a
puck it's got a picture of a candidate
on it if you make your shot your
candidates gonna win that's the rule
okay that's the game birdie there we go
there's Barney
Amy clover sorry I means if you make it
English Lida Clement Sean is gonna win
nobody who wants Biden I got no takers
no takers on Biden then everyone got a
shot wow that's a lot of misses we got
one more word right here Warren
who was that who was that Tulsi Gabbard
so Tulsi Gabbard is the winner
apparently and if the results of our
little hockey poll were about as chaotic
and inconclusive as the race itself I
can't say this
the Tulsi Gabbard PUC definitely found
the net president trunks definitely did
not
[Applause]